hello there reject nation greg
john we're gonna watch a video from new
rock stars per the newest tradition i
suppose the mandalorian season two
episode three easter eggs break down
hidden details i think they're the best
at doing this and i always love watching
them right after watching an episode of
the mandalorian by the way you should
check out our reaction to that if you
haven't already
go ahead link in the description box
because they always point out things
where i'm like
definitely didn't pick up on that thanks
eric voss i'm assuming that's you in
this video
let's swing into action
welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 3
chapter 11 the heiress an episode that
will make you hate quorns even more but
that's what they're called make you love
clone wars even more
for the live-action arrival of boca ton
crees and
someone finally telling did jaron no
dude you're the weird one take off your
damn helmet and stop drinking that
kool-aid oh and be sure to check out
wikileaks if you haven't already i
couldn't be there this week but
tommy and phillips seem to have it all
under control in this video i'm gonna
break down
all the interesting easter eggs star
wars references hidden visual details
all the stuff that you might have missed
you know the drill oh and yes i am
wearing our custom
this is the way shirt it is available at
new rockstarsmerch.com
if you buy it for a few bucks more you
can write in a custom shout out in our
wikileaks episodes
what an opportunity all right let's get
started
okay the opening shot of the episode is
the opening shot of the season two
trailer the battered razor crest
drifting past the gas giant coal island
toward the estuary moon
trask now the orbesh on mando's screen
translates to
stabilizer error and then moments later
landing gear offline
setting up this close call rapid descent
to the trask harbor zone
i love how this descent kind of sets up
the key plot device of the final
activity episode
where those mandalorians use the
imperial freighter needing to clear the
harbor zone first in order to hijack it
before its rapid ascent
an ascent that is reversed to another
rapid descent into the populated harbor
zone after
and there's some more great production
design details from the show as they
burn up during the atmosphere entry
condensation
drops from the bulkhead showing how this
process is less of the you know typical
clean space travel we always see in the
star wars universe and
instead more like what the early nasa
like bryce dallas howard
daddy except this extreme heat causes
the water in the b-roll
i also appreciated how that proximity
alert on mando's landing
uses the same sound effect from other
ships we've seen in star wars when they
get a lock on the target
but the crazier most insane detail is
the
orbesh here this is why i always try to
translate it these letters translate to
the words of course i still love what
sci-fi reference to
a name of one of the two sentient ships
and ian and banks the player of games
from the culture novels the other ship's
name was just read the instructions
elon musk also named his spacex drone
ships as a reference to
[Music]
two things we can all agree on nobody
wants anything bad to happen to baby
yoda ever and nobody likes wet feet
it's just those two lucky for us that's
who makes these great knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and weatherproof
they are super breathable too with an
interior
[Music]
which is insanely light considering they
are stronger than your feeling than
they're also made with the space age
dynamex material so these are shoes that
you can wear every day no matter the
weather
they're also sustainably made and super
easy to clean
whether you're in the weather moisture
snow it's running around town in winter
weather
besties will keep your feet warm and dry
and looking great
oh no my shoe got in the pool water but
wait a minute
my toes are suited
[Laughter]
so go grab yourself a pair for the rainy
season while they still have
sizes and you can thank me later check
them out in the link below and if you
miss a black friday sale use my code
new rockstars to get 25 off your bestie
shoes
now the crane that dredges the razor
crest from the water looks like a
retrofitted 8080
or at both are okay so let's leave it at
that but what i love about this one
being used this way is that lucasfilm's
art team originally designed these for
the empire strikes back by taking
inspiration from the massive port
cranes in oh neato
function on trask are aquatic beans the
quarans and the mon calamari like our
old pal admiral akbar
both are native to the ocean world mon
cala aka doc
and they've never really gotten along
they did actually have a civil war
during the clone wars era but
skywalker was able to broker a truce
between them now a little detail in the
pub i love is how corns
season their food after pelimoto
preferring her meat
medium rare it's just fun to see another
example of culinary preferences
these kind of choices have been what
john fabreau was referring to
when dave bologna said things like a
dime a dozen don't exist in the star
wars universe
and mando pays the pub owner with some
squishy flan currency
which we also saw back in the first
episode and then uh from baby yoda's
chowder a squid
latches onto his face xenomorph
facehugger style
another example of the alien motif we
saw a lot of last episode now the quorum
boat that they take out looks like a
retrofitted hammerhead class corvette
the one another famous mon calamari
admiral raddus used to
knock disabled imperial star destroyers
into each other during the battle of
scaraf in rogue one but those
dirty trickster quarrens trap mando by
feeding baby ota to a mama core this
i think is a nuke beast in the star wars
universe but it's interesting to note
that mando's jet pack seems to work
underwater apparently
but mado gets saved by dank ferrick boca
tan crees
played by katie sackov and axe wolves
played by simon cassian 80s
from agents of shield and royce gary's
wwe star sasha banks now boca tan is a
hugely important character in the star
wars animated series clone wars and
rebels she was once a member of the
death watch but she left that group
after maul took over the group and then
used them to steal
ball is so cool
former ruler of mandalore and one-time
love interest to obi-wan kenobi
hello there chronologically we last saw
bogatan
in star wars rebels she was wielding the
ancient
mandalorian sword of the dark saber and
using it to
unite the mandalorian people but most
recently in our time we saw her in clone
wars season 7 right after ahsoka helped
her retake mandalore but right as order
66 was about to go out
it is so cool to see these night owls
fight look at the gearings and sith
percussion is so intense
and the three of them move so fluidly i
love the use of the jet pack
with the wire effects what i like about
it is it's an interesting contrast to
the way
mando fights he has a more defensive oh
just let anyone hit me
approach because he is a loner and he is
learning how to be part of a tribe now
boca dan's helmet and armor are painted
with these owl markings just like they
are on the animated series you can also
see it on their shoulder patches these
are for the night owl group this is a
group she formed after leaving the death
watch
and you are a child of the watch yeah
poketan is reminding us that amanda was
actually saved by that previous group of
hers
the watch thus their three prongs oh
yeah when they opened the hatchback
into poketown much needed clarity about
why mando was so strict about never
removing his helmet
yes not all mandalorians are this strict
but it's just his group
he's a kind of cult of zealots that
broke away from mandalorian society to
rebuild after the purge
using strict ancient traditions to do so
and when they free baby yoda from the
mamacore his carrier is dented i've
always found it interesting that that
carrier is designed
to look like an egg a bit of ironic
justice for that little fatso eating all
the eggs
now his egg gets swallowed yeah later
tan declares her objective
receiving those weapons and using them
to retake our homeworld
once we've done that we'll see danny
mandalore on the throne
that planet is cursed anyone who goes
there dies
once the empire knew they couldn't
control it they made sure no one else
could either
don't believe everything you hear
interesting so apparently the empire has
been using propaganda to try to scare
mandalorians from trying to return to
their home world which does connect with
how moth gideon used that war crime
tragedy term the night of a thousand
tears but as a leader of the mandalorian
resistance bogatan obviously sees that
defeat as totally reversible now they
plot to hijack this imperial gozanshi
freighter a ship that we have seen in
the animated series and briefly in the
background of most espa
when qui-gon and the others arrived in
phantom menace mando leaves baby yoda
with the adorable frog couple whose eggs
now begin to hatch into tadpoles meaning
they have been
fertilized from the night before
these sirens frog sex
show craters since empire they brought
that back and it is captained by this
imperial commander based on his insignia
played by
titus wellever aka the man in black from
lost love this guy and if you look
closely on the bridge display the orbis
translates to
breach i do love how these stormtroopers
report that there are 10
pirates maybe more when yeah the pilot
just reads at the thermal scans verify
there are only four of them
idiots comedy actor kevin dorff cameos
is the imperial officer who
locks them in the cargo control area
allowing the mandalorians to blow them
out the cargo door now bokeh tan says to
the bridge
put some tea on we'll be up in a minute
this is some example of some consistent
universe details like in clone wars tea
is a big thing for the people of
mandalore like pre-vizila drinks it with
maul and pre-vizilla was voiced by john
fabro
time for tea come join me i didn't
realize
john favreau voice introduced all this
so all this episode is like a big
reunion that's why we fans are really
loving it now poketan aims specifically
to get the dark saber back this is of
course the sacred mandalorian sword that
dates way back to ancient times
this tells us that mock gideon must have
taken the saber during the purge but the
fact that she wasn't certain that he
took it suggests that
she didn't lose the saber in a duel with
him face to face but that maybe he like
snatched it away while she was elsewhere
during that fight
interesting so it sounds like this
imperial group are as insanely committed
zealots to their lost cause of the
empire as mando's tribe is to his
way now we know after the empire
collapses kinda reminds me of a
political joke i wanted to make sure
what might that be that could have been
part of what gideon did with the purge
they got some plans they want the child
they're doing something could be clone
related could be connected with the
empire secret plot to resurrect
palpatine and rebuild the sith fleet
that we see a generation later in the
rise of skywalker so i gotta say
i hope not i kind of want to forget that
i keep forgetting that these movies are
canon
[Laughter]
as if he is sucking out his suicide pill
in that moment and then later when he
bites down on it it dries his jaw oh
[Music]
and ahsoka finally reveals to us tomato
can find ahsoka tano
who's probably gonna appear next episode
played by rosario dawson and i love how
i don't think we have seen any of that
footage in any promo footage or trailer
she apparently is on the forest planet
corvus
in the city of caledon which as well are
new
locations in the star wars
this is a way telling it back to her a
sign that this guy
might have finally moved a bit in his
stubbornness and his dogma
closer toward a place of religious
tolerance that final image leaves a tiny
tiny little piece of that poorly
repaired razor crest behind
almost as if to say mando's character
shell is starting to wither away to
reveal the beautiful human soul
underneath that is all words or it was
just
this channel funny get yourself apparel
and accessories new rockstars that's a
very important piece subscribe to the
rockstars
button follow me at ea boss follow me
rockstar see you next time i
have spoken
hello speak well eric hell yeah man
what does dank ferric mean somebody
tell me i mean it sounds to me like a
ferric perhaps is some kind of creature
that is you know prone to becoming
especially
moist and gamey or something you know
i'm glad
you have all the right answers john
either that or it's goddammit it's the
same
uh it's one of the two there's some neat
things that uh that
they pointed out here in this video that
have me kind of wondering where the
story might be going forward from here
on out i mean but firstly there's like
some cool little easter eggs of course
the one with the of course i still love
you like oh yeah to me it's just such a
that's not even
like a star wars easter egg seeds far
beyond that at that point atats and the
port cranes we saw that with the
the last episode with the spider how
that was supposed to be used for empire
strikes back it seems like they do a lot
in this show
to try to bring things full circle
constantly things that weren't used or
things that haven't been brought to live
action whether that be books or comics
or the show themselves like with
poketown throwing them here into the
live-action series i think is just
wonderful
one thing that kind of hit me when
watching this particular
new rockstars video were the themes
about being a mandalorian
the first episode dealt with the cobb
character
themes of the armor and then the second
episode deals with the theme of like
honoring your word
when frog lady is using the zero droid
you're supposed to honor your word get
off your ass mando
and then and this one it's dealing with
variations of the religion of being a
mandalorian of how
not all them are the same you know yeah
he's being directly confronted with
people who he shares a relation with but
also who have yeah markedly different
viewpoints that could
easily drive a sincere chasm between
them and so yeah
i think that's actually a great way to
look at that and break that down in
terms of this progression sort of
confronting his identity yeah here's a
guy
who's totally not mandalorian rocking
the armor yeah
but doing it for ar arguably a decent
reason and then yeah mandalorian himself
having to
really examine the way yeah as he
upholds it and then yeah and then
looking at the bigger picture of that in
the third episode they have the line of
this
is a way because we've heard the line
this is the way so many times and i
actually think that flew over my head
uh when we watched it the other day of
this is a way
of showing like there's not only one way
this is the way
i was actually wondering people might be
confused by that part when she does take
off her helmet because they don't make
it
totally clear and i think there's some
people who when they did watch it who
haven't seen like clone wars they're not
that familiar with boca ton
wait a minute why should she take off
her helmet she gives a little bit of an
explanation here but i'm kind of
confused why she's taking off her helmet
because they made such a big deal about
it
in the first season it was such an
important thing for mando to not take
off his helmet yeah when they do it here
she does like it's no big deal but i
really love when you get her perspective
on it of like
a bunch of cult zealots guys
let it go are good to go good systems
and turning them into these
fundamentalists ridiculous yeah
what he confronts with bogotan at least
in those kind of spiritual elements of
mandalorian culture
i mean that's the kind of thing that
happens i think to a lot of people in
natural life and i like when sci-fi
story stories explore that gray area and
you see the growth here and i love that
visual illustration to
what eric drew comparison of between how
they work as a team she's a leader
and then when it's time for mano to have
his moment to shine he just kind of goes
in there
he lets himself get shot by all these
blasters he's still
learning to work as as a unit and work
with others i mean we saw him work with
others in the previous season
not to the extent like this where he has
an opportunity to really work alongside
other mandalorians and a team that is
fully formed versus like a ragtag crew
of people who are really kind of
tenuously on the same mission yeah i
really do wonder because
there are some things that uh i didn't
quite latch onto
the first time we watched it that was
pointed out here about the
propaganda element that the empire is
throwing towards
the world of mandalore of trying to keep
people from trying to go back there well
i'm like
it makes sense to me i mean mandalore is
constantly in shambles it's constantly
being overtaken or overruled and it
doesn't seem like there's
conflict within the mandalores all the
time it can be a hostile environment so
i didn't read much into it but the idea
that the empire is pushing some type of
propaganda and bokeh tan is going
against it
it's making me curious to see because
she has to come back
you know even though mando exits this
episode she has to come back because she
is the one and search the dark saber
and so i do think we have to see we have
to see how moff gideon took it i i feel
like it'd be kind of annoying if we
don't see it there's got to be a
flashback
episode or extended sequence because
that seems like a very significant story
to want to touch
they're going to show it and they're
going to recreate the last jedi scene
when luke is
standing over kylo ren and they're just
gonna face swap
uh luke with moff giddy and kylo would
vote
that is a you know they have the
technology course corrected
yeah it's poetry it rhymes
you know yeah that's an alternate
timeline
very similar to this time yeah we have
to see that because then you know her
whole goal to reclaim mandalore i wonder
if we're gonna explore that or if
it's setting that up in a way for season
i don't know if we'll go there in season
two i mean it would be
great to see actual mandalore in
this show at some point that would be
awesome to see that and if
he's part of the fight to help bokeh
town reclaim mandalore
i would love that i mean because
mandalore so heavily explored in the
animated series that
it would be really cool to see if how
they could bring it to life yeah and the
fact that they had like an
accurate costume for boca ten i'm
wondering how accurate they could go
with real life production value
bringing what's been animated into live
action oh incredibly accurate
especially in the star wars world but
yeah just to bring that up
even and have them have the little
quarrel about the merits of
trying to go back and reclaim it like
this seems like a pretty juicy thing to
potentially bring us into and to
literally in the shoes of our of dinjar
and enter that myth and see if it holds
true you know like that's yeah that
would be a really
cool place for the season to go maybe
season three will be called
the mandalorians yes and then it will
just be the whole homeworld
oh boy and i love also too a little
quick note about the koreans and then
mon calamari because accordance for my
recollection they were portrayed a
little bit more
often falling on the wrong side of the
war here you have a little demonstration
of that here mount calamari helps out
coran's betray yeah yeah
can't trust the quarantine
dank ferrix dank ferrix
sultan there's chowders all right guys
well
mandalore in season two episode three
leave your thoughts down below
hey subscribe to me rockstars if you
haven't done so already get some other
t-shirts we should get a t-shirt yeah
maybe we should hit them up be like yo
we've been on rogue theory a couple
times can i get a t-shirt
pay us in t-shirts pay us in many
t-shirts subscribe
click that notification bell check out
our amanda reaction if you haven't done
so already
last but not least
scuba steve there's six people out of 30
patrons every month that john
weirdly seems eager to shout out all the
time
so john take it away scuba steve i hope
you i hope you're okay today i just want
to express
well wishes and healthy energy because
you've got a new job
and it sounds very high stakes keeping
people i mean you know
helping the elderly and also keeping
them shielded from their relatives you
might bring code
and that's that's a lot man and uh just
to hear all the things that you've gone
through over the course of this
quarantine like i'm glad that you're
working again but also it sounds
like a job that requires a lot of mental
fortitude so i just hope that you're
taking some time out for yourself
and uh you know jump in a hot spring and
bring some eggs
relax man self-care love you and uh
we'll catch you on the next one
hope you had a good halloween too horror
movies hell yeah
and now i'm going to glance at you for
approval that was great john thanks greg
i just wish you didn't say the c
[Music]
word
[Music]
you